on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
it was the social media post that
unleashed a multi-million pound war of
the wags a public face-off that pitched
two high-profile women against one
another a seven-day trial that saw their
most personal secrets revealed to the
world
the so-called wagasa christie trial
between footballers wives colleen rooney
and rebecca vardy captivated the nation
and last week the three-year saga came
to a climax with vardy losing her libel
claim
the judge called her evidence manifestly
inconsistent evasive or implausible
the widespread conclusion is that her
reputation is in tatters
but what does rebecca vardy think
is this the final chapter in the saga
and how does she feel being the most
vilified woman in britain tonight in an
extraordinary interview rebecca vardy
tells her story
let's start at the beginning where were
you when you first heard about colleen's
tweet and how did it feel
um i was in dubai with jamie um
pregnant
it was going to be our last holiday
before baby came along so we'd gone out
international break
um
gone out just have a bit of sun and a
bit of down time
um
and
we were in day two into a holiday
and um
got up in the morning everything was
fine
um we're getting ready to go out to go
meet our friends at a beach beach bar
and um i started to get messages through
on my phone saying oh my god if you've
seen us and
usually if i'm on holiday i don't tend
to look too much at my phone unless i'm
speaking to the kids or
um
what have you um
and
i got sent a screenshot of
something that had been put up on
twitter
um facebook and instagram consecutively
within minutes of each other
um
kind of reading it
i had this
most overwhelming dizziness fuzziness
disbelief really
what i was reading
and what did you do
um we were in the taxi
we got to this beach place this beach
bar and walked in
i don't know it just i can't to be fair
it was so traumatic i can't really
remember exactly what happened then but
all i remember is jamie getting me out
there pretty quick because i thought i
was just gonna
pass out
um
just through the biggest adrenaline rush
i think i've ever experienced and did
you ring colleen or did you text her or
try and find out what happened um on the
way back in the car
um
she messaged me saying i
i've tried to call you
so i tried to call her back no answer
and then i can't remember who it was
that finally got through to
um
if it was me or whether it's her um
when i finally did speak to her i just
said
what on earth is this what have you done
and um
she
very aggressively and colorlessly said
you you know what this is
and i really didn't
really had no idea
why she would say that and where it come
from
um
and that conversation wasn't very nice
at all
um
very odd bizarre
were you upset did you try and i was
devastated yeah absolutely devastated
because
i didn't do it i didn't do it when she
first put it out there i didn't do it
you know all the way through this
process i didn't do it yesterday and i
still sit here today and still didn't do
it
well we've now had the verdict
so it's been a couple of days yep give
me your reaction how do you feel about
it
um
i'm really disappointed um
didn't really expect it to go that way
um
but i think we had a judge that
didn't understand the case and didn't
look at everything it feels like
the judge just read what was
written in the in the media and
took on their um narrative bias i mean
the judge said that your evidence was
implausible and that colleen's evidence
was truthful and honest do you think
that's fair
no i don't agree with that at all i
think
you know i went into court telling the
truth and you know and if that is
what happens to someone that goes into
court and explains
certain things and
explains their side of the story i felt
like i was on trial
on trial for doing the most horrendous
things
the judge in the end found that because
you had
leaked stories or given stories to the
press before
that she was fairly certain that she was
happy that there had been no libel
do you think that's a fair judgment
first of all i have never given stories
to breasts i've never leaked stories on
anyone
yeah there are a few messages that read
differently but
i think if you looked at anyone's
messages
out of context without knowing the tone
of two people
they can be interpreted in completely
different ways there's some things that
i'm not not proud of
but there's absolutely without any
shadow of a doubt i never leaked any
stories on colleen rooney
but there was a story that came up about
peter andre for example during the trial
yeah that was an example of a story that
you had given to the press but i didn't
leak that um that was a story that i put
my name to and it was something that
i deeply regret and i'm deeply ashamed
of but
it was so it was so long ago you know
life for me was so different then and
i tried to explain the situation in
which that came up and
you know i just think that was
wrong for
him to have brought into that situation
he had nothing to do with it that had
nothing to do with
what i was accused of
do you feel like you've been made out as
the villain in this case and that
ultimately this was maybe even trial by
media you've spoken about the fact that
there were lots of negative headlines
about you and the fact that you believed
the judge didn't treat this case fairly
yeah i definitely feel like i was made
out to be the bad guy everyone everyone
you know has to be painted in certain
lights and you know unfortunately i took
the character of the villain in this
do you think colleen really should share
some of the blame
um
look i think she did what she did and
you know she did it for her reasons i
think it was terribly timed i think it
was
quite cruel and quite unkind but
she did what she did and i just wish
that you know she would have given me
the opportunity at the time to
to have a conversation with her to
you know deal with it
privately
and
discuss certain things without
putting stuff out there to the media she
knew what what was going to happen off
the back of it
um
and it's just
such a shame that she didn't but i hold
no malice towards her or ill-feeling or
anything like that have you spoken to
her since the birth
i haven't spoken to her um
i made an attempt to contact her in
november
of last year
in a private message
and
she
didn't respond to it she just gave that
straight to the lawyers what did you say
to her in that message just basically
said you know
it was
i didn't i didn't do it we can still
sort this out you know we could we could
have sorted it then and we still can
because her team say that they did give
you opportunities to
withdraw essentially to stop this from
going as far as it did and that you
chose not to do that
if that's their version of events i
wouldn't class that as any form of olive
branches or settlement i mean i think
that anything any suggestions like that
you can't
enter into settlement negotiations with
people that are being aggressive
um
and trying to offer settlement basically
saying that i accepted blame anyway
so to me that is not the way it went at
all do you think there's any blame in
this that you should accept there's any
part of it that you should hold your
hands up and say you know what yeah
there was something that happened here
that wasn't quite right no because i
didn't do anything wrong um and i didn't
i didn't do it you know there's
lots of people that probably have given
stories you know i still see
lots of different things in the media
about her and
you know i feel like
i was
enemy number one and target number one
um
because there's still stories running
all the time do you think that part of
this is about the fact that maybe you
you were aware or you may even have had
an inkling even if you weren't fully
aware that stories were being sold
because of access that you had or
stories were being given because of
access that you had
i didn't even think about it in any way
like that at the time it was
people have conversations unknowingly
and you know
unintentionally talking about other
people and
it wasn't something that crossed my mind
at that time you know it was
conversations that people were having in
part in and
there was lots of different people
having conversations about them at that
time so i didn't see
why i was any different yeah we're
talking about conversations with your
agent between you and your agent the
court heard that stories from colleen's
instagram account could only have been
leaked by rebecca or her agent caroline
watt with or without rebecca's knowledge
mrs justice stain said that rebecca
decided caroline watts should not give
evidence partly because she knew it
would be shown to be untrue lawyers for
caroline said she was not well enough to
appear in court
on the third day of the high-profile
libel claim the judge heard how caroline
watt had lost her phone in the north sea
just days after the court ruled its
content should be
searched how do you feel about her in
this you know she wasn't part of this
trial she hasn't had to answer questions
about it
um
it's really uncomfortable to talk about
someone that has been made so ill
by this from a mental health perspective
so unwell
you know she's had threats she's had
lots of different things she's
been attacked by
by the legal team by colleen's legal
team and in ways that should never have
happened
i never called her as a witness
because i knew how
bad her mental health was
but
throughout this whole process at the
beginning in the middle
and then she's always reassured me that
she had nothing to do with this
do you think she feels
bad about it and i asked that because
obviously
in the court case it did come out that
she had said it was me that she was
responsible for one of these stories do
you think that she feels that
responsibility
um
it's not a conversation that we've had
it's not
a conversation that i'd want to
talk about with her just purely because
of i'm so conscious of
her mental well-being and you know how
how it's affected her as well so you
don't feel let down by her
well come on you can't ask me that
it's it's difficult it's difficult but
obviously part of this conversation is
about
you know the conversations that you guys
had which formed part of this this
process and that is really difficult to
talk about i totally accept that but but
you know there is do i feel do i feel
let down i feel let down by a lot of
people a lot of things but most
importantly i feel let down by the legal
system and i feel let down by the judge
for for not understanding this case
properly do you wish it hadn't gone as
far as it did
we tried different things to to
ensure that we didn't end up where we
ended up but ultimately
did i have much choice i didn't do
anything wrong i didn't i didn't do what
i was accused of what else was i'm gonna
do i was being vilified
i was having i had abuse sent at me left
right and center my children
and
you know i i desperately tried to to
stop it
um but ultimately that didn't work
you've talked about some of that abuse
before and i know it is a very difficult
subject but i do have to ask you because
some of it was really quite vile
how does it feel when you come back home
at the end of the day and yes you're
protected in your house but all of these
horrible comments are still getting in
because they're coming via social media
how does that feel
it's horrible um
it's not nice you you're aware of it
even if you're not
directly reading it you you know that
it's being sent you know that it's being
sent to your children
um you know that the kids at school are
saying stuff behind your kids back
um
it's horrible and it's it's not
something that you can control and you
know social media is
a vile platform sometimes and it's
something that you know really needs to
be addressed
and people need to be more responsible
for what they're saying to other people
because some of the stuff that i
received was just
unforgivable on all levels colleen must
have seen that too she must have
understood the impact that that was
having on you and this is one thing that
i don't understand you know again i
don't hold no ill feelings towards her
but
if that had been me i would have said
you know whatever i say that she's done
she doesn't deserve her family don't
deserve to be abused the way they are
because
if anyone's abusing her now if anyone's
sending any horrible messages or her
family any horrible messages and just
need to stop because
no one deserves
to be subjected to that sort of abuse on
any level
so why do you think she did what she did
in the way that she did because it was
very public that post on social media it
did attract a lot of attention and it
invited a lot of criticism what
did she have ill will towards you before
because you two were friends up until
this point
it's something that i ask myself a lot
it's something that we've asked a lot
and
it's not something that we've really
ever had
you know an explanation for but you know
she thought she was doing the right
thing and
i suppose you can't take that away from
someone when they think they're doing
something that they truly believe in do
you think she could have been jealous of
you
jealous or what
well you've spoken previously about how
you have a very strong marriage you have
a very happy family that's not
necessarily always been the case for
colleen and her family
no and i feel sorry for the for her in
terms of
the press that she's been subjected to
the
you know the constant spotlight on her
marriage the constant speculation but
i can't comment i wouldn't talk about
anyone's marriage that's
something for them and you know i can
only comment and and focus on me and
what i've got and you know i have a
happy marriage and i am happy with my
husband and we love each other dearly
how hard has it been on your marriage
because for even the strongest couple it
must have been a really trying couple of
years
i would say it's been
harder in terms of jamie watching what i
went through
and
having to
you know see
me so upset
see me so stressed
um but also knowing that
when i'm going to football games i'm
going to be subjected to
horrible chants
there was a point that i had to stop
taking the children to football
because they were the opposition fans
were constantly singing
you know horrible stuff about me and i
didn't want the kids to be to be
subjected to that sort of abuse because
as a parent all you want to do is
protect your children
ultimately sometimes it's out of your
control and you can't
um so
that was the hardest part for us was
dealing with
the repercussions of the accusation
not that it put any strain on our
marriage whatsoever because it hasn't in
fact i'd say that it's made us stronger
and more
more more as a unit he must have seen
you at some really low points that must
have been really difficult for him yeah
definitely i mean he was in hospital
with me when i got taken into hospital
with kidney stones when i was really
poorly um when i was at the lowest of my
loads with this with the stress and the
anxiety and just not wanting to
even function even get out of bed in the
morning i mean you know i think for
any partner to see their wife or
husbands like that is just
you're at a loss coming up was there a
point where you just thought god i
cannot do this anymore i just i'm just
done you're watching the news test
special rebecca vardy colleen and me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
was there a point we just thought god i
cannot do this anymore i just i'm just
dumb was lots points there was lots of
points that i went through
feeling
didn't even want to be here anymore it
was
like the worst feeling but
at the same time having those feelings
feeling that i shouldn't be feeling that
because
to me that was
being a failure and that was
not an option for me to be seen to be
like that
for the kids benefit more than anything
i was going to ask you about that
because there must have been days when
you felt i don't want to get out of bed
i don't want to leave my house did it
become quite isolating
yeah it did
but then i blame myself for that
isolation because
i think when you're
going through this
without being pregnant might have been a
different thing but then you add all the
pregnancy hormones into everything the
emotions that come from that
i was trying to be mum to the kids to
you know four children that were here
and i had to try and
protect my baby as well because i'd been
told in no uncertain terms if this
stress didn't calm itself there was a
real high probability that i was going
to go into preterm labor
and that really scared me and
from then on i just thought
no matter how hard it gets
it can't get much worse than what it's
been so i have to now try and turn this
around for the kids and be there for
them and redirecting that kind of
negativity to try and turn it into a
positive
was something that
my counselor really helped me with
and gave me tools to be able to do that
you've seen a counsellor you just
mentioned that but have you had to
i mean have you been diagnosed with any
anything as a result of this have you
had anxiety have you had to take
medication has that been i was on
medication um i had really bad anxiety
attacks
and
there's probably a good chance that i
will end up having to go back onto
tablets
but you know it's nothing to be ashamed
of you know if that helps then you know
i'll accept it because i think everyone
has to know their strengths and their
weaknesses and a point where they need
to ask for help they need to ask for
help
you've talked about hospital before i
mean that must have been very difficult
for you what was the most difficult
moment throughout all of this
knowing
how badly it was going to affect the
kids um
the kids at the beginning were having to
be driven to school in cars with bin
liners up against the windows because
of the press intrusion here
it just went crazy it went crazy from
you know i was
just a normal mum and now i'm a mum no i
was being a mum that was being called
all sorts of things you know in the
press and so on social media
and it's horrible because
for me at that time i didn't want to
leave the house i didn't want to do
anything and
i just wanted normality to resume
whatever normality is anymore i don't
know
um
and i felt for the felt for the kids i
felt for the ones that were innocent in
this ones that were being subjected to
things that
i couldn't control
how have you explained it to the
children because you've said before that
you have a
policy of complete honesty that you are
very open about everything and there
have been some really difficult moments
in this case yeah how have you dealt
with that so my eldest she knows
i tell her not to read stuff but i think
the more you say don't read something to
a 17 year old the more that they just
want to go and do it
and i think for her is you know
reading stuff about
her mum or seeing stuff about her mum
that she knows
is not true
and um i sat down and i just said to her
look in life
some people will like you and some
people won't that's just part of life
you know
you've got to concentrate on the people
that love you the people that care about
you and ultimately the people that know
the truth
and that's the way i've been all the way
through this you know don't read the
press don't don't do this if you want to
know anything you've just got come to me
and we'll have that conversation
and i think it's important not to give
them too much information and to shield
them from from
some of the stuff that's going on
they're too young to understand you know
why any of this happened
i mean i don't really fully understand
why most of it happened but
as a teenager
i can only imagine and i just wanted to
be there to support her through it and
and i think
for me that
kind of
got me in a situation where it pulled me
out of the dark days because i thought
yeah this is about you
but
you've got to focus on your family
you've got to help your kids because you
can't
become that person that doesn't want to
go to bed in the morning that doesn't
want to go out that is
you know at the early stages i didn't
want anyone i didn't want to be seen i
didn't want to be you're doing anything
and i thought this can't go on you know
you've got to get a grip and
try and get back to normal you've spoken
about abuse before but but following
what's happened and the high profile
nature of it you know do you ever get
people coming up to you walking down the
street do you ever get that that kind of
abuse held at you in person that you see
online um at the beginning yeah it
wasn't nice i'd
go out to the shops
and you know someone had walked past and
go i can't believe you did that you were
disgusting
um
and shout things across the road and and
stuff like that and that was one of that
the reasons i kind of started with
drawing and not wanting to go out as
much
but generally
the bad abuse is is mainly social media
which is why
something has to be done about the way
it's
police the way it's monitored because
it's wild absolutely wild
there are some people who say that
because you live your life on social
media many people do but particularly
celebrities high-profile people that and
there's an element of that that you
bring on yourself what would you say to
those people
yeah i don't understand that narrative
because
i post pictures on on social media
because it's a way of me controlling
what i want to put out there what images
of my kids i want to put out they're not
going to a football game and have a
photographer taking pictures of you know
the kids or
or me or you know and it's a way of
allowing people to have a bit of an
insight into your life
because people do like to see you know
and um
but
retaining that that control
why do what what is it that makes you
want to show people into your life
because i feel like
if i don't someone else is going to do
it for me
and it's always been that way and you
know and and that's the reason i
first started doing interviews was
because so many
lies were coming out about me so many
things were being said that are so
negative and so false and the whole
image about me that was being portrayed
was just
a total lie that i just decided well i
either sit back and accept this which i
was never gonna do or i was gonna fight
and i was gonna put my events out there
what i wanted out there what the truth
was do you think part of the reason why
you've taken this so far is because of
that control you need to have that
control
no because i was out of control with
this i didn't have any control over this
situation whatsoever it was a way of
me
taking back or trying to take back what
i was wrongfully accused of and trying
to
deal with that situation
is there any part of you that regrets
this whole process that wishes at the
very start that you could have found a
way between you and colleen to just stop
it from ever going to court oh my god
yeah definitely i wish that
hindsight's all well and good isn't it
but i wish you'd just picked up the
phone and just had that conversation i
wish we hadn't had to go through the
process of
lawyers
courts etc but what's done is done and
you know it's time to
move on because there will be a
significant legal bill to pay and that
will fall to you does that worry you no
not at all um
legal fees will be dealt with privately
the way they should be you know there
shouldn't be any gloating about anything
to do with finances or anything and
you know that should be something that
is dealt with through through the
lawyers because there's lots been lots
of conversation in the press about you
being forced to sell homes to deal with
those costs
oh yeah there's been lots of things
about lots of stuff but i don't read the
press um i've taken a decision not to
read anything
and when i do or if it's pointed out to
me i learn something new every day about
myself or that we're meant to be doing
all that we've done
there's been quite a bit of speculation
about
um
other poems abroad and yeah that's
category really not true that must be a
really strange feeling to read a
newspaper and think
that just didn't happen yeah that didn't
happen and where on earth does that come
from and you know
there's been times where
people have been told things aren't true
and it still gets written and you're
just like oh
it's exasperating it's exhausting um
but sometimes you just have to accept
that some things are not in your control
and you know deal with the things that
are so can you see why i suppose colleen
rooney felt so strongly about it because
you've just articulated that feeling
there it's really difficult when you see
something that's not true about you
which is exactly how she felt so can you
understand you have sympathy for her
um i'm sympathetic to
the situation she thought she was in but
in her own witness evidence you know she
said she wanted the stories published
and she intentionally put false stories
out there to be published and there's
been numerous
stories all the way through about
about about her and numerous things and
and i'm sure they'll they'll continue i
just feel like i was made to be
a target and
um
you know
someone wanted it all to fall onto me do
you think i mean you just said she did
she did want those stories to be
published do you think there is a part
of this that
you know she does like that attention
she seeks it because that is part of her
profile it's part of her persona
i don't know you know
it would be hard to be drawn into saying
anything negative about her because i
just i don't have anything negative to
say about her at all nothing
whatsoever
my criticisms fall to
the way i was treated in court and and
the way you know certain members of her
legal team behaved i want to come on to
that in a moment but do you think that
you will appeal this the verdict
it's in the hands of solicitors a minute
you know we'll let the dust settle we'll
we'll read through all the documentation
or when i say we
they will and um i'm sure we'll probably
have conversations in the future about
what's next if anything and you know
what we do
talking about the court and perceptions
of court you know your outfits were
really scrutinized all the way through
this court case as were colleen rooney's
do you feel like there was an element of
sexism in the coverage of this case
totally the whole thing is
was presented
in such a misogynistic way i mean you
know when johnny depp was going through
his court case there was hardly any
articles if any about how much money
he'd spent and you know his outfits but
it just seems like
women aren't allowed to defend
themselves women aren't allowed to
you know dress nicely
yeah
there's a lot of sexism involved in it
you think amber heard got a raw deal
um
i didn't to be honest i didn't really
follow the case too much i think the way
she was treated in court yes yeah
because you you have spoken about david
sherbourne and the way that he treated
you and he was actually reprimanded for
the way that he spoke to you at one
point yeah david sherbourne was colleen
rooney's barrister for the trial he's no
stranger to high-profile cases having
represented johnny depp and meghan
markle before but the judge at times
questioned his tone when he
cross-examined rebecca vardy in court
how did that feel on the stand in that
court
horrendous i still have flashbacks of it
now
um
i felt like i was bullied i felt like i
was
shamed
for stuff that i'd done
many many years ago that had no
bearing on the case whatsoever
and i feel like i wasn't given an
opportunity to answer the questions the
way they should have been put to me
um
but you know that was obviously
the way he wanted to go with it and
you know yeah it wasn't a nice
experience at all
he was making the point in court that if
you were going to sue for libel your
character is in question and that's why
he brought those things up that's why he
brought up questions about previous
stories yeah can you see why he would do
that
no not in the way he did you know i
think it should have been based on
what the accusations were i mean i was
always threatened from day one with
their legal team that if i was to pursue
this that i would be character
assassinated that was always a thing i
told you that yeah
um
so i knew i knew to some extent you know
what they were trying to do to me the
stuff that was being
put in the press and you know having to
read the defense first hand in the daily
mail
we didn't read it through
my solicitors i read it through the
press
and what do you think that says about
the other side
i don't know i'll leave that for
to be open to interpretation coming up i
think he wanted to make me quiet i think
that was the ultimate goal you're
watching the news test special rebecca
vardy colleen and me
i'm julia hartley brewer and this is
talk tv i think my most memorable and
proudest moment in journalism over all
these years is actually being on air
during the lockdowns even when i had
coveted myself over the last two years
getting people to tell their stories not
just about people who lost love wants to
covet but people lost their fundamental
freedoms their children's schooling
their mental health their physical
health their businesses and giving
people the chance to tell their stories
about how it affected them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm tommy dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did his interview went on one of the
more rules he's gonna launch a nuclear
strike on north korea or open up a shark
pit that i then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview
[Music]
what was the most distressing moment for
you
during that case
um
i think the most distressing moment was
probably we having to talk about the
abuse
but the way it was handled was
it was brought in at a time where it was
clearly
brought in to cause maximum distress to
me
to maybe to make me feel vulnerable
and confused and
you know upset
i think he wanted to make me cry i think
that was the ultimate goal was was to
see me upset
why do you think he wanted that
i don't know
the judge in this case said that she
believed that you didn't understand or
couldn't
couldn't fully contemplate your role in
all of this that that you are
essentially in denial about it do you
think she's right no definitely not you
know i wouldn't have pursued this for as
long as i had if i
you know given stories to the media
i i
i mean anyone who thinks anyone would
put themselves through
what i've been through with this
knowing all along that they were
responsible
is just
insane yeah that is that's the question
isn't it that a lot of people have they
don't understand why you would continue
down this road i mean were you ever
warned by your legal team that this is
not going to go your way you need to
stop no because they knew i didn't do it
and and that is the exact reason that i
carried on for as long as i did and i
will say that to long blue in the face i
did not do it
did jamie ever say
you know i can't watch this anymore
enough
no he was always fully supportive you
know he was
110 behind me in fact he encouraged me
because
you know as did i he read the documents
he he saw what i went through and
he knew
what i was facing and he fully
encouraged me to do it
there were some fairly nasty messages
that came up in court between you and
your agent um that were read out
obviously that colleen heard that lots
of people that know you heard how do you
feel about those
i think most people if you went through
their private messages on whatsapp you'd
find something in them talking about
things that shouldn't be made public
that you know was not fit for public
consumption
and yes i do swear i'm not going to
apologize for that
and we say things sometimes in messages
that are taken out of context
and unless you read
the full
messages
you don't really understand people's
personalities you can't just take a
snippet of a conversation and
you know make an assessment based on
that did you apologize to colleen for
them
for what for those messages no for that
language no
do you think you ever would want to
um
it's something that i
thought at the time and it's you know
i'm not i'm not going to apologize for
a message that i sent privately
do you think if there were an
opportunity in the future for you to
to come back together to have a
conversation have a glass of wine would
you welcome that would you want to do
that yeah of course you know as i said i
don't wish her any ill feeling
whatsoever maybe
one day we'll get a coffee together were
you good friends before this no i
wouldn't say we were good
friends i was
supportive of her when she went through
situations
um
we sent each other presents when the
kids were born and
you know we were just
generally nice to each other do you
remember the first time you met her
um
yeah
but that's not fit for camera
was she nice to you was she cold um
i found i've i don't know it was almost
like
i have spoken about this in court i the
first time i met her was like
the new girl going into
an environment that they didn't want to
accept
any new people into
there was already
this group of
of girls and
they weren't keen on having anyone else
involved that's how it felt they wanted
to shut you out
i wouldn't say necessarily shut me out
and and i'm sure that probably wasn't
the case but
football can be quite a toxic
environment
if you allow it
to bother you that is is it hard to find
your place in a world like that
yes if you're looking to find your place
in a world like that i never was
um
you know
football to me is
something that my husband does and does
incredibly well and you know that's
that's his place
and you know that's me going there to
support him
there are very few people who will ever
experience that world in the way that
you have
lots of people have said that the the
wag the wives and girlfriends lifestyle
is really isolating it's very lonely is
that how you found it to be
um to some extent yeah but i wasn't
really into
you know i didn't go to football games
to make friends i went to support my
husband and
you know i took my family i took my
friends and
wasn't there to mingle was that would be
nice but that wasn't
the reason i'd go to matches it was to
support my husband and
and that that was it but you know i've
been
in this football industry now with jamie
for quite a while and you know you see
things and you see things that are not
not pleasant sometimes and that's why we
tend to keep our lives very separate
between football and and
you know personal life do you have close
friends in that footballing world no
no i don't think i've ever really had
close friends in football um
i've got a couple of friends that i've
had for a while probably for a while in
in that circle but
players come and go
and you know you'd be making friends all
the time and to be honest i just don't
have time to do that anymore i've got
five kids and
you know when we go to football it's
there to support daddy and and that's it
did anyone from that world from that
group of girls that you've spoken about
did they take sides did they shun you
how have people reacted to you after
that after all this i didn't get people
involved this wasn't anyone else's fight
and it wasn't
positions i wanted to put people in i
don't want people to take sides that
wasn't what it was about
you know this was something between her
and i and that's the way it should have
stayed
um
people shouldn't be forced into you know
being friends with someone i mean it's
like it's like being 12 years old again
isn't it in the playground
um
yeah it wasn't like that if you had
supportive messages from people yeah
i've had lovely messages from people
really nice messages from people
really supportive ones
and um and that's nice to know and i
think when you go through
hard situations
you really learn who your true friends
are and that's why our circle is so
small
there have been um accusations that when
you first met colleen and you talked
about how hierarchical that group of
women was that you were trying to break
into that that you wanted to be
photographed that you even organized
photographers and a lot of people do it
but that you organize photographers to
take pictures of you
listen i have always always said that i
have done set up pictures i do do set up
pictures but again it's a way of
controlling something
that you've either got a book coming out
that you want to publicize or you're
doing something that you want to
publicize and anyone
in this industry that pretends they
don't do certain pictures
it's just ridiculous if you do it own it
you know there's no shaming in having
your pictures taken none whatsoever
and i'll probably do it again
and there's no shame in that you know
why
why people
don't tell the truth about doing set-up
pictures goodness knows you know the
daily mail is filled with it
everyone knows that that's the way it
goes in this industry i mean there are a
few times that you do get caught out by
a photographer and not flattering and
they're awful
um
but in terms of
i mean it's ludicrous the whole if
you're referring back to the 2016 euros
intentionally sitting behind someone to
generate publicity at football game when
there's
in a different country
god knows how many
you know fans are in that stadium
goodness knows how many photographers i
mean it would take
someone to really really know what they
were doing to pull them but you would
all have been sat in the same place
because those those spaces were reserved
for people who were coming with the
players and how is that any different to
setting up a photo
you don't know where you're sitting
until you pick the tickets up
but how is it i suppose that's what i'm
trying to understand how is it different
if you're accepting that's totally fine
to set up a photo how is that any
different
well one that didn't happen
until you're going to be pictured anyway
because you're in a stadium everyone's
pretty much sat scattered around all in
that area
and um
why would you need to but it wouldn't
have been a big deal to have done it
because and if i had i would have said i
had you know to me
if i had done it you know like i just
said then it's
it's no big deal to me if i have done
certain pictures so
if i had done that i'll just turn around
and open it
can you see why the lines sound like
they're blurred
no
no because i don't understand how you
can be accused of setting up a picture
in a stadium full of people not knowing
where you were sitting
beforehand
and doing your own setup pictures
knowing where you're going knowing where
you're going to be knowing that the
photographer's going to take pictures
of just you
it's very different are you still in
touch with any of those other women yeah
a few of them yeah and were they
sympathetic when when what did they try
and help you
like i said before a lot
i didn't involve i didn't talk to them
about i didn't want
them to feel like they had to take sides
because that wasn't what it was about
it's not about taking sides
and and
and yeah
i still speak to a few of them
occasionally
what's what comes next for you now do
you have any concerns about where you
can go from here um
i think for me first and foremost is
taking a breath
you know looking at all the
opportunities that i've been given so
far that i've got
and then deciding what's best for me to
do
do you worry that it might be difficult
for you to
to find work that you want to do
meaningful no i've had i've had there's
been quite a few offers on the table of
lots of different things
already and you know
i think for me it's really important to
find something that
inspires me and something that is
meaningful and something that i
really really want to do i want to ask
you a difficult question it's something
you've spoken about before um it's abuse
that you suffered when you were younger
when you were around 15 years old
and i want to ask you about that because
one of the things that you said at the
time and it really stuck out for me was
that you found it really distressing
that people didn't believe you yeah and
that people said that you were making
things up
that's what's happening again now yeah
people are saying that they don't
believe you yeah and that you're making
this up
how does that feel to go through that
again
now as an adult
it's hard it's challenging
um
but i've dealt with it once and i've
come out of it the other end and
i'll deal with it again and come out of
it the other end you know
you can only
allow yourself to be
controlled if if that's the way you
you know that's the way you want to go
and i refuse to let it control or define
me
do you think there's some part of you
that wants to
to make people believe you do you think
that's why you pursue this so
determinedly no it wasn't um
i didn't do this for the public to
believe me i didn't do this for anything
but
because that's what i truly believed in
and that's what i truly believe in and
that's what everyone close to me and
everyone that knows this case inside out
i didn't do it
is there any part of you that wants to
bow out of the public eye now
i do know what i did go through stages
of of thinking that and then i thought
i don't know we'll
no probably not but
you know you'll probably see me doing
things that are different
i want to concentrate on my horses you
know
my horses and and their kids and
you know
rebuilding all that
kind of lost time that i've i've had
dealing with all their stresses and
stuff and
re-challenging and refocusing and
putting my energies into
doing positive things now what would
your message to jamie be given his
support throughout this
uh
you may be
crying i don't know it's a tough one
it's quite a private one as well but um
i think it would just probably be
you know thank you
for just supporting me through
everything
and
not just him but the kids
i'm going to end on a lighter note okay
the lionesses yeah they won
it's amazing
but they are now going to be thrust into
that spotlight on the same spotlight
that you were thrust into someone once
told me um
get ready to be
thrown into the goldfish bowl and that's
exactly what it'll be what will happen
to them
but you know oh my god how amazing was
that and what an incredible incredible
thing to happen to
you know england and
at least they managed to do it
he's not the man the men
i know we've not had much luck have we
but you know congratulations to them
they're you know incredible role models
and
you know more women should look up to
them and especially girls and it just
shows you know if you really set your
heart on something and you really really
want to want to achieve something no
matter how
how many hurdles you have to cross to
get there you know if that's your dream
go out there and fight it all the way
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers allen in brisbane
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big step this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor the family
of archie battersby have been told his
life support treatment will be withdrawn
at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning the 12
year old has been in a coma since april
today his parents lost an appeal to have
him moved to a hospice to die the
conservative party hustings in
eastbourne were disrupted this evening
by protesters who heckled liz trust
during her opening speech after they
were evicted the foreign secretary
described them as militant activists and
vowed to crack down on unfair protests
and if you're looking to clean your car
or fill up a paddling pool this weekend
you could face a fine of up to one
thousand pounds a hose pipe ban is now
in place in hampshire and the isle of
wight due to the ongoing dry weather and
low water levels
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
the biggest issue in britain right now
has to be cost of living how much
everything is costing all of us to get
to work to pay for food to pay for
electricity and energy and that's not a
problem that's going to go away anytime
soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you